Man vs. Wild star Bear Grylls has actually
got quite a few side projects that help keep
that cash flowing even when he's not in front
of the camera.
Here are some of the highlights from his financial
journey over the years that have helped him
mint his fortune in spades.
While it isn't everything, the successful
survivor's television career has obviously
served as a critical piece in founding his
financial fortune.
Man vs. Wild, his first blockbuster show,
was watched by over a billion viewers.
But in more recent years, the Discovery Channel
sensation managed to leverage his growing
popularity into several other shows, including
Running Wild, in which he's taken numerous
celebrities with him on his adventures in
the wilderness.
"Let's, uh, let's really discuss our plan
here…
“I think on these journeys it's always step
by step...Really.”
“Right.
You don't think we should stop and discuss
a plan."
According to The Richest, it's estimated that
Grylls raked in a whopping $30,000 per episode
and that was just during his stint on Man
vs. Wild.
Since then, the numbers only seem to have
gone up.
Needless to say, there's no doubt that Mr.
Grylls' personal fortune has received a healthy
boost from the years he's spent in front of
the camera.
"I think if somebody said to me at age 7 that
I could have a job that involved climbing
trees and getting muddy, I would've thought,
'heaven.'"
Television career aside, Grylls has also made
several savvy real estate investments over
time, the most impressive of which has to
be the island he owns in Wales.
But we're not talking about a dirt-rich celebrity
dropping a ton of cash on a fancy new island
just for fun.
According to The Telegraph, Grylls actually
bought the island in 1999, over five years
before Man vs. Wild started up.
The island, which he considers one of his
best investments, covered 20 acres that came
with a cottage in need of renovation.
He spent the four years following the purchase
scrimping and saving up enough money to make
repairs.
In 2008, Bear estimated he'd spent 100,000
pounds on the project and that it was worth
a cool million.
Call it old school if you'd like, but when
The Telegraph asked how he preferred to pay
for things, Gryll's answer was short and simple:
"Debit card because then there's no risk of
getting into debt."
Even when he was still getting started, Bear
refused to fall victim to the "swipe and forget
it" mentality that plagues the modern consumer-driven
world.
While he may have the gusto to buy a fixer-upper
island, that doesn't mean the man spends money
at the drop of a hat.
In fact, he's demonstrated an ability to be
cautious enough to ensure that his personal
fortune remains in the black.
Mr. Grylls has carefully curated his persona
as a tough-as-nails survivalist, but he's
also built up an impressive side career as
an accomplished author.
His lengthy list of book topics includes survival
tips, lifestyle advice, his own personal experiences,
and even a number of children's series.
A catalog of books that big by one man is
an incredible sight to behold on its own nevermind
the fact that for Grylls, it's a side hustle.
Sure, he might already own an island and be
paid tens of thousands of dollars per episode,
but when you consider the fact that he'd reportedly
sold over three million copies of his books
by 2015, the amount of influence that "Bear
Grylls the author" has played in building
his fortune becomes a bigger deal than just
some cash on the side.
For a man who's spent much of his life showing
off his skills by surviving with next to nothing,
the guy seems to have managed to make bank
on his merch sales.
According to the Evening Standard, he was
estimated to have brought in over three million
pounds in merchandising in 2015 alone.
So what exactly does a man who eats maggots
and pees on his clothes sell?
As it turns out, the Bear Grylls merch line
includes everything from his famous Bear Grylls
Ultimate Pro Knife to a water bottle that
also serves as a lamp and power source.
While merch sales are hard to pin down on
a consistent basis, there's no doubt that
the sale of his own products has created some
lucrative side income for Grylls.
While there's no doubt that Grylls has a boatload
of money, he's made it clear from early on
that just because he has more than he needs
doesn't mean he throws money away with the
little transactions.
As he told The Telegraph, he's tried not to
convert the money he earns from his U.S. shows
into British pounds because he doesn't want
to lose cash in the transition.
Instead, Grylls put his U.S. dollars into
an international investment fund, where it
can gain value without the need to go through
any switch over to U.K. currency.
While it seems like a small detail, it comes
from a mind that is clearly focused on making
the best possible decisions at every turn.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.